resuelve para x y tenemos x 8 es igual a
x sobre 3 más un sexto y lo que voy a
hacer aquí aunque hay varias maneras de
hacer esto lo que yo voy a hacer aquí es
simplificar las fracciones para esto voy
a multiplicar toda la ecuación por el
mínimo común múltiplo de todos los
denominadores
aquí tenemos x sobre 18 sobre 1 x sobre
3 y 1 sobre 6 el mínimo común múltiplo
de 13 y 6 es 6 y que va a pasar al
multiplicar todo por 6 lo que va a
suceder es que se van a eliminar las
fracciones así es que al multiplicar
estas que inicialmente las fracciones
por 6 que nos resulta 6 por x menos 6
por 848 estamos distribuyendo el 6 esto
es igual a y del lado derecho tenemos x
sobre 3 por 6 vamos a escribirlo tal
cual esto es 6 por x sobre 3 más 6 por
un sexto ahora el lado izquierdo no se
altera 6 x menos 48 lo cual es igual a 6
por x sobre 36 sobre 3 es igual a 2 esto
nos va a dar 2 que multiplica x
2x + 6 por un sexto 6 sobre 6 se
cancelan y queda simplemente 1 así es
que este primer paso nos sirvió para
cancelar las fracciones ya tenemos una
ecuación con coeficientes enteros que
podemos resolver directamente ahora lo
que queremos hacer es llevar las x a un
solo lado vamos a llevarlas del lado
izquierdo vamos a restar 2 x a ambos
lados me quiero deshacer de este 2x por
eso estamos restando 2x estamos entonces
2x del lado izquierdo y 2 x del lado
derecho y que obtenemos del lado derecho
tenemos 2 x 1 - 2 x se cancelan las 2x y
nos queda tan sólo el 1 del lado
izquierdo tenemos 6 x menos 2 x es 4x
cuando tenemos 6 de algo menos 2 decía
algo nos dan 4 decía algo 4 x menos 48
ahora necesitamos deshacernos de este
menos 48 para esto sumamos 48 a ambos
lados de la ecuación sumamos 48 vamos a
ponerlo con otro color sumamos 48 del
lado izquierdo y 40
del lado derecho con lo cual ahora
tenemos 4 x menos 48 48 que se cancelan
y nos queda tan sólo 4x y del lado
derecho nos queda uno más 48 49 ya
llevamos las x del lado izquierdo y
ahora para despejar x multiplicamos por
un cuarto o lo que es lo mismo dividimos
entre 4 dividimos entre 4 el lado
izquierdo y dividimos entre 4 el lado
derecho del lado izquierdo 4x entre 44
entre 4 es igual a 1 nos queda tan solo
x lo cual es igual a 49 cuartos es lo
más que podemos simplificar pues 49 y 4
no tienen factores en común comprobemos
y 49 cuartos es realmente la solución
sustituyendo ese valor en la ecuación
original recuerda la ecuación original
la tenemos aquí en verde antes de que la
multiplicamos por 6 en teoría podríamos
sustituir el valor en cualquiera de las
ecuaciones pero vamos a hacerlo en la
ecuación original así tenemos x menos 8
es decir 49 sobre 4 menos 8 que es igual
cuarenta y nueve cuartos sobre tres más
un sexto bien y ahora qué hacemos
podemos hacer lo mismo que hicimos para
resolver la ecuación es decir
multiplicar por 6 para deshacernos de
las fracciones vamos a hacer eso vamos a
multiplicar por 6 toda la ecuación y
vamos a eliminar las fracciones entonces
multiplicamos por 6 el lado izquierdo y
multiplicamos por 6 el lado derecho y
que obtenemos 6 por 49 cuartos 6 cuartos
se simplifica como 3 medios
así es que esto es igual a 3 por 49
sobre 2 menos menos 6 por 8 48 lo cual
es igual a 6 dividido entre 32 x 49
cuartos nos da 49 medios 49 sobre 2 más
6 por un sexto 1 y aquí entonces lo que
podemos hacer creo que lo voy a calcular
directamente había pensado restar 49
medios a ambos lados de la ecuación y
así simplificar los cálculos pero no lo
voy a evaluar directamente para
verificar la identidad
hagamos entonces 49 por 3 aquí podrías
pensar que es 3 menos que 3 por 50 que
es 147 pero vamos a la multiplicación
directamente 3 por 927 llamamos 2 3 por
4 12 y 2 14 147 así es que esto es 147
medios menos 48 y 48 lo escribiré en
términos de medios 48 es igual a 96
medios 96 sobre 12 48 así es que esto
sería menos 96 medios esto es igual a 49
medios más 1 que lo voy a escribir como
dos medios ahora cuánto es 147 menos 96
si fuera 147 menos 100 tendríamos 47 y
si restamos 4 más
obtenemos 43 no no no tenemos que
sumarle 4 pues nos estamos quedando
cortos entonces sería 147 menos 147 más
4 51 51 medios
y esto es igual a 49 medios más dos
medios 51 medios así es que la solución
obtenida es la correcta